le réalisateur jean françois lévesque se
faisait une joie de présenter cet été le
film sur lequel il travaille
minutieusement depuis six ans au
prestigieux festival international du
film d'animation d'annecy
mais la pandémie en a décidé autrement
quatre tombes et finalement c'était ses
théories à prendre parce que c'est j'ai
pas beaucoup d'opportunités dans une vie
à la autant que ça me prend faire des
films je réponds coup de barre de portes
unités de vivre ça à défaut d'une
édition traditionnelle
le festival se tiendra cette année en
ligne il sera accessible partout sur la
planète
c'est quelque chose de nouveau que
jamais eu lieu donc en même temps c'est
sexy tant de poids participer à quelque
chose de nouveau
annecy et 20 autres grands festivals de
films dont cannes lexsi foutry des cas
ont uni leurs forces cette année pour
présenter we are one un grand festival
présentées sur youtube qui permettra aux
amateurs de cinéma de visionner
gratuitement jusqu'au 7 juin ou de son
film partout sur la planète
une solution de rechange qui ne remplace
pas pour autant les festivals
traditionnels prince ignace c'est là où
le film prend naissance est vraiment oui
pour la première fois il voir là la
rencontre avec son public avec
l'industrie avec ses pairs c'est
vraiment un moment charnière dans la vie
d'un film pour l'instant l'industrie
cherche le modèle le plus adéquat pour
rejoindre le public
si oui un wade présenté mondialement le
festival de documentaires aux ducks qui
se déroule actuellement a pour sa part
choisi de rendre sa programmation
accessible seulement aux cinéphiles qui
a des tendons arriver
le festival international de films sur
l'art été l'un des premiers à devoir se
tourner vers une programmation en ligne
au début de la pandémie
ses organisateurs n'ont eu que quatre
jours pour faire le virage numérique
mais ont reçu de très bons échos on a
réussi à toucher beaucoup de gens dans
tout le québec dans tout le canada
des gens qui autrement n'auraient jamais
eu l'occasion d'avoir accès au festival
il faudra probablement être patient
avant de retrouver les tapis rouges et
les grandes soirées première mais en
attendant les cinéphiles ont quand même
de bons films à découvrir à la maison
disney bien alexandre charti radio
canada montréal